hey this is presto Walker reminding you
to mind your decisions this is said to
be the world's toughest riddle and it's
going viral in India I have 50 rupees
let's do some accounting on how I spend
it if I spend 20 I'll have a balance of
30 if I then spend 15 I'll have a
balance of 15 if I then spend 9 I'll
have a balance of 6 and if I spend at 6
I'll have a balance of zero the total
amount in the spend column will be 50
now what's the total amount in the
balance column whoa it's not 50 it's
actually 51 and this is the puzzle where
did the extra 1 rupee come from this is
a really fun problem and you can
translate it to your local currency
you'll be surprised by how many people
around the world don't understand where
this extra one rupee comes from pause
the video if you'd like to give it a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so to better understand this problem
let's illustrate what's going on we
start out with 50 units of currency
let's compare the amount that we spend
versus the balance remaining if we start
out spending 20 will remove 20 of these
dots to the spending column and then we
have a balance of 30 well what happens
if we spend 15 we then remove 15 and we
have a balance of 15 so far so good now
we spend 9 which leaves a balance of 6
and then we spend that 6 and of course
we're going to have a balance of zero so
actually all of these numbers are
correct the total amount that we spend
will be equal to 50 the question is why
is the total in this balance column
equal to 51 well the reason is there's
actually no problem with the numbers the
correct equation is that the balance
plus the total amount spent will be
equal to 50 it's not going to be true
that the sum of the balance column will
be equal to 50 sometimes it will be but
in this case it'll be equal to 51 let's
think about this problem a little bit
more abstractly let's suppose we spend s
1 our balance will be 50 minus s1 and we
then spend s 2 we have a balance of 50
minus s1 minus s2 if we then spend s3 we
subtract s3 from the balance column we
then have s4 and subtract that the total
amount in the spending column will be
the sum of these spending amounts and
now the total amount in the balance
column will be this function 200 minus 4
times s1 minus 3 times s2 minus 2 times
s3 minus s 4 if we put in the amounts
from the original problem we can see
what the result is for each of these
columns so all of these numbers will
actually be correct the total amount in
the spending column will be 50 but now
the balance column when we evaluate this
function we get a result of 51 and
that's fine it doesn't have to be equal
to 50 so if we go back to the original
tape
it's completely correct and there's no
problem with the numbers it's just a
trick question to compare the sum of
these two columns and he'd be surprised
by how many people get confused I
challenge you to ask 10 people and see
how many we'll figure it out and it's
okay if they're confused because now
you'll be able to explain why the 50 and
51 are not equal to each other thanks
for watching and for making mind your
decisions one of the best channels on
YouTube thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]